[Applause]
no one has control of Hong Kong streets
yesterday protesters were under siege at
University tonight
they laid theirs at a police station
setting up production and supply lines
bricks petrol bombs ferried to the front
the peace broke out the demonstrators
scattered they trained their weapons on
us there are no protestors around this
is a new more dangerous phase protesters
are trying to shut down the city and
it's working
students from the Chinese mainland were
today escorted across the border as
schools tomorrow will be shut the first
time this has happened you are they
young oh yeah that thing you've gone
come rolling every one of us must
cooperate together to tell the others
that tolerating violence might encourage
it if we continue to foster the violence
in Hong Kong the consequence is
unthinkable it is an ominous warning but
all of this was unthinkable at the start
of the summer this is just outside the
university and they've made an
absolutely huge roadblock is the fruit
of an afternoon's work and you can see
how far it stretches strewn with bricks
in this formation this is a new tactic
actually it stops police advancing but
it also means protesters can smash a
brick into to make it easier to throw
any advancing police it's all part of
this new determination these new tactics
there's new energy from protesters so
Hong Kong prepares for yet all violence
Tom Cheshire Sky News Hong Kong